so for the fourth day of Christmas we
have four different drink receptacles
first we have a mug from Russia which is
part of a project on supercritical
fluids my area of research then you
probably know I collect plastic water
bottle and Sam tank just brought me this
one from Hong Kong new sort of water
bottle from Hong Kong
they're usually green now this is a blue
Watson's water bottle Brady who doesn't
really like my water bottles brought me
this one from San Francisco where he
films number file his maths Channel and
if you turn it round you can see it says
boxed water is better I don't agree with
him and then finally there's a vodka
glass which I really quite like because
it's got my surname Polyakov on it
though it's not spelt quite the same way
and some of you may have seen our video
on vodka
Mendeley vodka and of course Polyakov
vodka so watch it if you haven't so for
our fourth day of Christmas
for drink receptacles three chemical
badges two periodic table bed covers and
a piece of tartaric acid from a Swiss
wine barrel let's see what happens for
day five
well if you've heard there of them are
send sequence because this famous and
question that we don't know how to
answer is are there infinitely many
prime numbers in this sequence since
this question is so hard one easier
question we could ask would be
what are the prime divisors of each
element of this sequence look like that
seems like a hard question well it might
be a harder question depending on how
specific you want to get